okay great uh all right to introduce our
next speaker Patrick Essa is a principal
research scientist at Runway focused on
machine learning for Creative
applications so he was also a developer
of stable diffusion and vqan and part of
that same conference group at University
of Heidelberg uh Sir Patrick so great to
have you here and I'm really looking
forward to seeing some of the
applications that you're working on and
also yeah just all your other thoughts
on uh what you've been what you've been
doing with these incredible models
yeah great thank you
um can everybody hear me yep it's
perfect
and I think I can go through the slides
in here right
yep nice
um yeah thanks for helping me really
glad to be here
um
my talk is called food for diffusion
um
basically I just want to talk
well I guess like the the one point is
uh to talk about
to give a bit of food for thought also
what one can can work with uh on the
fusion models
um but the other part of the title is
basically that I will talk a bit about
the inputs to to the model and how that
affects the output
so essentially what I want to start with
is that composition is something that
matters a lot for Aesthetics
um so
here this is a nice example I guess from
Um moonworth's Kingdom by
um
yeah which
which always has like really nice
compositions and this is in a way where
it really becomes kind of clear that
there's something going on something
specific about the composition of the
frames
um while still being beautiful so I
think
this will be generally a quite a hard
goal to reach that kind of uh quality in
in the Aesthetics how how scenes are
composited
but
um yeah I think we are it's definitely
something we should strive for and while
those are uh not generated they've been
made by a human master
um at least like he has something like
the first slide
um that is generated
yeah so
basically for composition I guess
um I'm not really an expert in the topic
but I guess like you could on a high
level say that the relative position of
different objects in a scene that make
up the the image
um it matters right
so
on a very very basic level you have to
think about like
um
positions in images
um
yeah I think one should also say like
even though
even though we train on huge databases
like Lion
um which come from everywhere and
contain
all kinds of different content
um it should one should still
uh realized that it's like we don't take
even those pictures are not random right
like
um
even people like me who are not aware of
uh good compositions or anything even if
I take a picture I usually take a
picture of some object so
we can generally expect is that
um images will be object-centric for
example already puts like a weak bias
into the data set
and the questions then really kind of
like okay how can the model actually
um figure out where to put objects be
that for matching the object-centric
prior or be that for
um coming up with good compositions
so
kind of like as a thought experiment if
you want
um
is the idea like imagine you're a
convolution like usually or for example
uh for for energy diffusion models we
the backbone of the diffusion model is
often a unit which mainly consists of
convolutions
but completely true there's also we also
use attention most of the time
um nevertheless
um
yeah if you if you look at the basic
operation of a convolution
it's like you use a fixed set of weights
and slide that over the window right
so you apply the same
um functions though to say
uh through every point in the image you
slide it across
so
now with the diffusion model if you
sample eventually like your first step
will start from a Pure Noise image as
shown on the top right here right
so
if if you're a convolution kind of and
you get your input which really consists
only of noise and you see two different
noise patterns it's basically impossible
for you to tell where you are in the
image like two patches in a year they
just look absolutely the same
um so basic questions exactly like how
well we know that it works right like we
do get object-centric samples out of the
model
so
um the question is actually like where
does that come from
and
it's really nice work about this by
Islam at all uh on
in a bit of a con different context not
for challenge with models but for
discriminative models
um which analyzes first of all like how
much position information
[Music]
um convolutional networks encode and
also
analyze the the mechanisms of uh of how
that works
and yeah I guess like one of the on a
high level the the
high level finding or one of the
conclusions is that
um one way that cnns do get Precision or
do encode processional information
is through a combination of having a
large receptive field and the fact that
we often use
zero padding for in combination with
those for convolutions right so here's a
visualization of of that principle
basically
um so if compared to the to the previous
slide we now have a model that has a
larger receptor field
and then if you're at some point in your
in your image you want to apply your
convolutional crown there but the
problem becomes like you will it will it
might be bigger than the image right and
so the simplest solution is to just
add zeros in that position
and so if you do that as visualized here
with the
um
the black borders basically
you see that now those two like what a
what a conclusion sees in those two
different locations actually it does
develop differ like now it sees oh on
the left there's a black border so I'm
probably somewhere on the left side of
the image and similarly for the right
patch you you can see that there is a
black bar on the bottom so I know I'm
somewhere close to the
bottom and of course like since all of
this is
um learned
um it might it might come up with very
sophisticated ways how that encodes the
position
um
yeah so
with this kind of like uh
idea of how
how actually like uh
a CNN and thereby also probably a
diffusion model actually orients itself
or like things about uh compositions in
samples and images
uh I want to digress a little bit uh and
go towards
textures right
so
sections I would say
are a bit different from our typical
images
in the sense that here it's
you wouldn't say there's no like real
object prior in the
in the images in fact I think one of the
things that is like a helpful
description is kind of like that they
look pretty much the same everywhere
right like you can look at any patch and
they kind of look very similar at least
like often a statistical sense
and
yeah so
in that case it might actually like
Clash a bit with uh
with the idea of having
um position encoded because you want to
look at the same
and also
yeah one
one also makes use of that uh idea that
textures kind of look the same
everywhere if you wanna generate large
textures right
often this will be like a a large area
that you want to paint without another
3D
um asset or whatever you you need to
create like potentially arbitrarily
large textures so
there are a lot of words on or like the
most basic idea is that since it looks
everywhere the same you can just take
like a small patch and then you just
tile it arrange it next to each other to
get
um
a larger texture
and
so one could try to do that essentially
with um with samples like a nice thing
that does work very well but like
um text to diffusion models you might
say like uh as a prompt you just ask for
a texture patch of the word right here
shown on the right is the
the result that you get out and the
curve makes sense it might make for a
nice uh nice texture if you can increase
the increase the size
but if you do that now you just dial it
as shown on the left side you can
clearly see that they're all like yeah
you can clearly see that it is titled
right so that's not very desirable it
doesn't really look good there is still
basically
um yeah there I would say there are two
issues one is
um that like the spatially it's not
homogeneous enough so there is still
quite a bit of structure uh in the image
which might come from something like a
zero padding General model nose and the
other one is the blending around the
around the edges right and yeah like I
said this has been I mean it's has been
extensively analyzed and there are many
algorithms for that
um for
doing proper texture tiling and one
approaches uh
um was described in his work by Heights
uh on high performance by example noise
using a histogram preserving blending
operator
which I think is really popular for
texture tiling and it performs often
very well
um
I think it's just that it makes like
again very rather strong assumptions
that what you that the image actually
can be described well by its uh
statistic
and yeah if you so if we apply something
like this now shown on the left
um the result is definitely improved it
looks uh much much more natural the
boundaries but generally speaking one
can still see like this structure of a
two by three grit right just because
there's so much
um this little structure left
so yeah if one takes a look at this like
padding behavior
um and if one thinks about that this
might be one of the core things how the
model thinks about position
and we want to get a more homogeneous
um
texture out of it
uh very simple idea is to just replace
you have an existing model
um
you just replace the padding mechanism
in all of your conclusional layers to do
like a circular padding and what do you
get out of that is then basically your
sample becomes
something like here shown on the bottom
right
and
without any post-processing so the image
on the left doesn't use any blending
you just
tile them together and you see that they
actually fit
which is yeah which is a really nice
property because now you can directly
generate those
um
textures and have them directly tileable
right without any post processing
and also without any any real changes to
the model
yeah so I think I really like this
example because it's I would say
well that's simple like both in terms of
you you can take an existing model and
just apply the change and all of a
sudden you get
um you'll get samples with completely
different properties just by thinking a
bit about how the model internally works
and
yeah maybe the other thing that really
surprised me for this example
is that that it actually works right
like often I would say
you have some intuition about how the
model Works regarding like the padding
um
but now in this example here we go in
and directly manipulate the way how that
is handled right and that changes like
everything internally all the internal
representations of the model
um and just the fact that
um
that this works is quite surprising
because I think you can there are so
many examples where you can
um really mess up the uh
model performance really quickly just by
um
by changing slight details like
I
I had issues where like I would train a
model with a very specific
um
resampling algorithms for resizing
training examples and at test time if
you would use any other it would like
completely fail so very often there is
this fact that models can
can overfit to specifics very strongly
but in this case it uh it really
performs nicely and produces the desired
result
okay
um that yeah the training data kind of
brings me to my
second point that I wanted to talk about
um which now goes again back to what we
started with and which is kind of the
opposite of textures
um that usually there is
compositional structure in images
so what we see here is basically the
first page that you find if you go to
the
website of the rely on Aesthetics data
set for relatively High Aesthetics
threshold
um and you see it in their
in their original form right
like all the images have different
aspect ratios they also have different
solutions they're just recessed for
visualization but I guess the the
important thing is like
um yeah they usually
have very different aspect ratios and
the other thing to note is that
actually more often than not they are
not square right
um I guess like the two most popular
formats are basically like either like a
um
landscape format something like this
which is like a white screen aspect
ratio or also like a portrait mode which
is especially popular for portraits
right but also for other images
enemy I would say
um that a lot of those images come from
artists who actually created them and
um I mean they usually put thought into
like how they arrange objects in an
image right that that is part of what
the image should Express
so
I think that's actually quite important
data but if you then look at what we
actually do quite often when we when we
train those models it's like I would say
basically a simple technical artifact
that we wanna
stack all our training examples into a
single tensor to have a good memory
layout that we can feed it through the
network fast right we're gonna
already takes long enough so you have to
make sure the performance is good
so to make that possible this stacking
of images what we usually do we just
extract Square images
resize them to a common size and we get
a batch that for this example basically
it looks like that
um
I mean the images still look
good from a first perspective but
um yeah like I said I think like in this
example it's not even that bad like but
we can often see like here already
indicated that hats get a little bit cut
off here and uh there are no more hands
visible
and yeah here the composition completely
changes where we where we did see
something of the background behind the
um ours here
so yeah I think it really changes the
the whole
um meaning or definitely destroys the
composition of the of the
intended original image right
and
okay as a consequence of what happens if
we do that right
um so we do this fixed size training and
then what we see like as a first first
observation just
um
regarding the the generalization is that
okay so we train on topically here this
this model is also trained on 512 by
5.12. uh and this resolution
um we get reasonably good images like
I did not excessively Cherry Picked
those here this one's definitely not
perfect but you can see like it overall
gets the chest and if you produce like a
quite a few more samples uh you usually
find pretty good good ones as well but
then you
um
try to do something else right during
sampling time it's in general it's one
of the nice things of a convolutional
model that you can just like
[Music]
um
change the change the shape during
during inference and produce samples at
different resolutions
um
yeah and I think this is relatively
interesting what happens here um you can
see often
if you go to like higher resolutions
um
you very often see this repeated objects
floating around somewhere in the image
and once again I think like if you yeah
if you think back to
the fact that the mall usually does
encode the boundary it was trained on
like it knows like there is a 512 by
5512 that's what I'm training at and
most of the time I do expect
an object like a person or something in
the middle of that image right
and that's basically what it's doing
here right like this is double the size
so I guess like the the most extreme
case would be like if you see like kind
of four
um four reasonable images
um
even though their composition doesn't
make sense right like their relationship
is just floating around because
um yeah uh
10 24 by 2024 image is not a random
combination of four five hundred twelve
by 5 12 inches so there we
um yeah we really quickly run into
trouble in higher resolutions
and something else that we
um
which is maybe even
a bit more surprising I find is
um that the same happens if we go to
lower resolutions like if for example
this model at 256 by 256 here in the top
left then it actually really
um
doesn't make any sense anymore so
um it was also interesting like hard to
tell what exactly happens it's like all
of a sudden now borders are overlapping
which
the model never saw so yeah I think
that's that's one of the points where I
mean like
um
yeah don't don't expect to get magical
generalization to all the cases right we
see it doesn't
um yeah and then yeah one thing we we
explored quite a bit now is basically
that we
train on Dynamic sizes so that means
both
that we take
[Music]
um
we keep the original aspect ratios which
is more about preserving the composition
of the scenes but we also keep the all
the original resolutions up through a
threshold so we train somewhere between
256 and 2048
um
and yeah what we see is definitely that
things improve quite a bit so for 512 by
5.12 we still get
um nice results in this case also maybe
an interesting composition might be
related to the to the different aspect
ratios as well
um for 2024 by 2024 it also produces
good results
um for 256 by 256. I guess you can see
that it's like a bit more well I mean it
is a lower resolution image
um also all looks a bit more washy but
that is also
um
actually like a yeah fact off that this
is also like a two-stage model and uh
the first stage also
um introduces reconstruction Euro set
at lower resolutions
um
yeah generally speaking I don't think
you want to go like to something 256 by
256 but uh it is actually important that
you can at least do like one size uh
smaller in case you want to do pretty
extreme aspect ratios right you want to
have might have like a very long side
combined with a very small side
um yeah and that brings me also to the
to the other point which I think is
maybe even more interesting is like this
um this fact about yeah composing images
at different aspect ratios
here uh as an example batch for
um yeah landscape
um mode on the top this is the one that
was trained uh on Dynamic sizes and
dynamic aspect ratios you can see that
it produces a
quite nice results often and it also
seems to have some
I mean I don't want to judge that I'm
not like I said I'm not an expert but I
think it's uh
can also be used to to explore nice
compositions of
like often like most of the time you're
interested in probably something like
widescreen or different formats and I
think that was something this you can it
provides much better tool to not only
explore like the specific content
um that you want to put somewhere but
also the the composition right you can
you can get inspired by that as well
um yeah whereas the the same model
basically with the static size training
at 5.512 again we already saw that
um doesn't make much
uh sense in this case we again see all
those
repetitions of
um objects in the center
yeah that one's just uh basically just
the same example but for portrait mode
um I think that's something that also
that I hear a lot
um people are also a bit annoyed with um
that often have you
if you do a port remote and you're
interested in in sampling like a full
body person
um all kinds of things uh funny things
happen like this one is very common that
you that it just cuts off the head right
which is related to what I was talking
about in the in the training batch
example
they're just often cut off and we don't
see it so
kind of not too useful anymore and the
other one is this duplication of bodies
which
sometimes really
provide funny looking outputs but uh in
general it's also not really what you
want right whereas we can see again I
think especially for this for support
remote uh with characters since we train
on their original size I think there are
quite a few of those in the training
data set
um we get much more
coherent
um generations of characters
yes
um time okay I think I'm
um yeah maybe I will stop here and take
questions if there are any
awesome thank you so much Patrick that
was a really you know deep dive into you
know sort of ways to make uh diffusion
models work which is pretty nice to see
because you know a lot of the time you
just see the output right like uh check
out my fancy image on Twitter and um
It's actually kind of revealing to see
that there's a fair amount of like
careful
um you know intuition in engineering as
needed to get this out
um we have a few questions from the
audience so one of the ones here
um from Evan Jones is uh based on the
way convolutions learn to orient
themselves in the image do you suspect
composition is better at the edges but
weaker towards the center where the
guideposts are fewer
yeah that's
really good question actually
um
I think there are two things that won't
have to differentiate with the
composition one is really this fact that
because you crop you never see the
original composition right so it's
in that case if you do the center
cropping it's much much less common that
you actually see like a
in a widescreen image that would be a
white screen image that you see like a
long stretch of nothing and then maybe
at like one third or something of the of
the scene you have like a portrait which
like might be like a common composition
so since you never see that I I think
like that is one problem why the model
would never really if you ask for a
product where it would never really make
a long stretch of nothing before it puts
a person
um
yeah so from that I don't think the
conclusions are too much involved but
definitely from the from the perspective
of yeah orienting itself
um I think actually that's
one can go quite a bit deeper into that
question and really ask a question like
why are we actually not providing it a
better way of orienting yourself right
you know you are there is the idea of
concatenating coordinates or uh some
some representations of the coordinates
um
to the to the data input and that kind
of often like depending on the task I
think it can really improve results
um
one reason why often white is not done
by default I think is because you again
even you you lose generalization to
other resolutions even more right
because now the model really
starts to use the the precise spacing
between points the the resolution that
you drain it if you change that then
during during sampling time it's like
really confused so I think that's why
you often don't do it but I think with
if we go to Dynamic size training
um this will be very interesting to
explore to see
because then yeah if the model sees all
the different resolution words and
different sizes then we might get the
generalization nevertheless
thanks yeah I it feels a little bit to
me like um in the space of diffusion
models we're kind of trying to
ReDiscover what are like the techniques
from computer vision that we've used for
decades and now what are the equivalent
ones right like you know we have all
these hacks for data augmentation which
work really well and I think it's pretty
much too soon right to know exactly you
know how you do this in the diffusion
process yeah yeah I agree I think that's
super interesting topics and also on a
very high level I think that's uh I'm
always excited about working with a new
technology while reading maybe some
um older paper and trying to see how
those ideas match or can help each other
and about football maybe we can take one
tongue-in-cheek question uh so you know
maybe this is the question of dynamic
training or resizing and stuff you know
will this fix hands and maybe a question
like part of that for me has always been
like why what is it about you know
stable diffusion that gives you these
like you know nightmarish like
interlocking hands what's the intuition
there like what is it about hands that
are like such a difficult thing to do I
mean I used to be a painter and I used
to struggle with like you know feet and
hands I hated them so my own images were
always like you know hands hidden but
like is it the same for diffusion models
yeah um I mean
uh actually I think we we already made a
bit of uh of progress there because I
mean it used to be that that it was
really freaky looking at uh faces that
were generated and often they still are
but uh but uh but we're getting pretty
good at them
um I mean yeah also there I think we
also talk a lot about that we definitely
think it's
there's this human part where it seems
that we're really overly sensitive to
human anatomy so we just noticed that so
much more than anything else
um
but then
yeah I think
at least what we saw also a lot when we
we trained a lot of this these first
stages which try to compress images
through a smaller representation and
then reconstruct it from there
and I would actually say that that
already there we very often observe that
like that faces look very strange and uh
especially hands and I really think it
is also related to the to the size of
those features
um
I mean it works better if you if you ask
it for a full front or close-up portrait
right because there's like
essentially if you look at it relatively
there are now more codes that that work
to represent the face then if you have
like a face that's very far away it
becomes much smaller and maybe there's
like only a high level if you look at
the receptive field of that code it
might be only a single representation so
yeah so there's more you have to
compress it more and that's where you
lose information and things get worse
um so I think that's a big part and the
hands are definitely more even more
difficult due to their size right
but we're good
yeah I mean I think already in stable
diffusion 2 you can see great
improvements so this is like it's pretty
exciting
you know that the great mystery of hands
will be sold
the biggest problem of all times
you know some people are you know doing
protein modeling and you know climate
change and we're worried about hands
yeah and consists of proteins
so yeah um with that I'd like to thank
you again Patrick for joining us it's
been a real pleasure and um yeah we'll
see you at the next event or yeah around
that's really nice to meet you hi
foreign